Russia's presidential election next
month just got even more predictable
Boris Nan's exclusion from the race
removes a man with significant support
even if he was unlikely to seriously
challenge President Putin for the top
job the main thing is that there's now
tens of millions who are going to vote
for me according to all polls I'm in
second place after Putin already in
double digits sources claim the Kremlin
feared that Dean would have gained more
than 10% of the vote if he ran but on
Thursday the central Election Commission
ruled him out of the
race let's vote on refusal to register
Boris borisovich Nan as candidate for
the office of President of
Russia anyone votes
against there are also no
abstainers tens of thousands of people
had keed at nadin's campaign offices
across the country to leave their
signatures of support it became the only
chance for them to legally Express their
anti-war sentiment in a country where
such views are considered to be an
attack on the Russian army and can land
them in jail Nadin needed more than
100,000 signatures of support to be
allowed to run but when the election
commission decided 9,000 were invalid he
failed to meet the target nadesan has 10
days to appeal to the Supreme Court as
of now there are four names on the
ballot president Vladimir Putin as well
as representatives of three parties in
the Russian low house of parliament the
state Duma none of them has an agenda
any different to putins Julia shavala Al
jazer
Moscow make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer